les moules que l'on mange sont à 95% des
moules d'élevage et elles proviennent
toujours de la mer ce sont des moules
marine
mais dans les lacs et les rivières il
existe une immense variété de moules
d'eau douce
elle joue un rôle crucial pour maintenir
la qualité de l'eau et vous allez le
voir dans certains cas leur façon très
inusité de se reproduire les rend
vulnérables
[Musique]
cette mulette perlière est
impressionnante ça paye tout atteindre
20 cm de longueur
elle peut vivre plus de 100 ans se
reproduire jusqu'à 60 ans
[Musique]
mais sa survie est menacée autrefois
abondante sur la côte est de l'amérique
du nord en europe jusqu'en sibérie et au
japon aujourd'hui elle se fait rare dans
plusieurs régions selon l'union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature
la population de mulette perlière a
chuté de plus de 60% dans le monde
depuis les années 1920
[Musique]
geneviève bourget et gérante doucet
caron sont biologiste au ministère des
forêts de la faune et des parcs du
québec depuis quelques années le
ministère répertorie ces colonies de
molette perlière de l'emprunt deux comme
ça très beau spécimen
il a disparu dans certaines rivières
qu'elle était plus pollués comme on
éveille ci aux bas salaires à un autre
colonie mulette perlière dans la rivière
kamouraska
auparavant la rivière kamouraska
s'appelait la rivière opère une mue
l'aide sur 1000 produits une perle
d'où son nom
nous sommes sur la rivière matane les
scientifiques ont trouvé plusieurs
colonies de mule est
mais si rien n'est fait ici ou si elles
vont disparaître ici c'est des mulets on
en retrouve pas en bois de 20 états donc
il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de bébé mulette
comment expliquer qu'une espèce qui se
reproduit entre 20 et 60 ans le gnr pâte
progéniture il y a plusieurs causes
possibles au déclin des mules est
l'abondance de ciment dans l'eau
l'intensification de l'agriculture la
déforestation la pollution la mulette
perlière filtre jusqu'à 50 litres d'eau
par jour
au fil des ans hélas cumulent du mercure
du plomb des bpc des organochlorés et
autres polluants
alors qu'en est il ici sur la rivière
matane l'habitant est encore superbes en
sait juste que le poisson on ne vient
pas jusqu'ici
donc il ya de la place pour établir
encore des colonies le substrat est bon
lowey éclair est belle la source du
problème se situe plus en aval il y a
plusieurs années on a reconstruit le
barrage sans et ajouté deux passes
migratoires
résultat les saumons qui sont intimement
liés au développement des mulets tu ne
peuvent remonter toute la rivière pour
frayer
il reste donc plus au nord au grand
plaisir des pêcheurs mais pas pour les
mulets tu sais que le cycle de vie des
mules est et complexe
chez les moules d'eau douce les sexes
sont séparés autour du mois d'août le
mâle expulse son sperme dans l'eau il
est captée par le siphon d'une mule est
femelle pourri féconder les yeux qui se
trouvent dans ses branchies une fois
féconder l'oeuf donne une large
microscopiques qui sera à son tour
expulsé dans l'eau l orage est oui c'est
bel abbès et les clochers dit qu'ils
doivent absolument se fixer dans les
branches une somme entre latine mais vu
que ya pas de saumon atlantique mais
elle les rejette mais il n'y a pas de
poisson pour les recueillir donc les
larves marc bellemare jérôme dousset
caron et spécialiste du saumon
atlantique ou ministère comprend qu'elle
n'en parlait plus de symbiose parce que
ces deux espèces clément qui cohabitent
ensemble sont carrément ceci donc la
mulette ne peut pas vivre sans mon île
son nom semble s'accommoder de
l'amulette parce que dans les rivières
ou les bonnes colonie de mineurs sont
présentes les populations saumon sont en
santé aussi les l'herbe demeure de 8 à
10 mois dans les branchies du tacon
elles deviennent deux minuscules milette
puis elle quitte les branchies pour
s'enfuir quelques années dans le fond de
la lumière dans l'est de l'amérique 7
c'est bio se fait avec le saumon
atlantique pour une raison inconnue
cette association est moins efficace
avec un autre poisson haute pour donner
un coup de pouce ou mulette le ministère
a décidé d'en semences et 26000
qu'incombe le saumon atlantique et les
colonies milette
ouais on est à 20 degrés donc c'est
pratiquement 5 degrés trop chaud pour
procéder aux anciens lancement en prêt
moyenne température d'environ 14 15
degrés dans petits ruisseaux qu'on a
pris tantôt il y avait entre 14° cette
part filmé dans la rivière à les
réchauffer trop vite donc c'est
impossible de faire les ensemencements
aujourd'hui ou dans les prochains jours
il faudra attendre des semaines avant
que les conditions idéales se présente 5
septembre
la température de l'eau a chuté à kege
degrés celsius est ce que tout le monde
un peu l'idée du terrain giron du ccar
on mènera l'opération dont le petit
bâton sera bon pour monter aussi
comprendre rhdp dans ce coin là on prend
des bonnes jeunesse pour le portefeuille
ici depuis le lancement il n'y a pas
tenté bain les sacs à dos avec eux dans
la journée sera chargée technologues de
la faune des biologistes du ministère de
la société des établissements de plein
air du québec de la réserve faunique et
de la société de gestion de la rivière
matane
tous sont venus prêter main-forte
transportation
sur le terrain l'expédition s'annonce
plus ardue prévu la sécheresse des
derniers mois a non seulement retardé la
remise à l'eau des poissons au cours de
l'été mais a aussi multiplié les algues
dans le lac et abaisser le niveau de
loups certains endroits sont
impraticables
le camion de la pisciculture arrive
enfin
[Musique]
on
les poissons sont mis dans de gros
boudins remplis d'eau et d'oxygène
ils sont transportés par bateaux sur les
sites choisis
pendant des heures la manoeuvre se
répète
[Musique]
dans la rivière l'état consent
finalement relâché
ces jeunes saumons au demeurant nivière
quelques années avant de retourner au
fleuve et à la mer le réensemencement va
se répéter au cours des prochaines
années il faudra attendre un an de plus
avant de savoir si les petites larves
expulsé par les mulets de femelles ont
bien réussi à se fixer aux branchies des
tacons les scientifiques savent encore
peu de choses sur les mulette perlière
cette année les nombreuses périodes de
canicule ont retardé l'avancée de la
recherche souhaite la libération des
larges des bougies 10 fait à quelques
pendant l'été qu'on sait pas exactement
la période ici en inde résidence pas
encore connue
sur la rivière matane les biologistes
espèrent encore sauver les colonies de
mai les permières question de préserver
la biodiversité
[Musique]
tout porte à croire qu'elle va
fonctionner parce que non densité des
mules être sont encore très bonne
notre population est encore en phase de
se reproduire mais le temps est compté
ailleurs elles ont disparu
[Musique]